je
nous
non
salut a tous fin de journée devant le
vélodrome pour vous parler d'une
discipline que tous les enfants ont rêvé
de faire près de 400 licenciés quatre
clubs là la réunion et pour nous en
parler frédéric técher et toi ta passion
sais quoi et moi c'est le roller c'est
parti
avec son maillot de champion de france
frédéric est un maillon fort du roller
réunionnais brevet d'état et compétiteur
il s'occupe de faire grandir ces jeunes
depuis plus de 15 ans
côté groupe ici pourra débuter cet
échauffement et ceux qui sont avec eux
je nie vous restez là et vous débutez
l'échauffement avec johnny ok c'est
parti deux groupes avec des objectifs
différents mais un partage de techniques
essentielles pour progresser et sports
écologique économique et qui allie le
plaisir est un mode de déplacement
après il ya un côté ludique aussi où le
ghana à points a anticipé parce qu'on ne
peut pas s'arrêter quand on veut où on
veut comme on veut
d'où l'intérêt du gamin à pouvoir
observer à mesurer le temps et la
distance et à faire le bon rapport
attentifs les parents observent leurs
petits champions tout simplement pour
une question de sécurité ça
ok là prennent réellement à avoir les
positions les postures pour s'arrêter
amman
au départ c'était pour jouer et après
s'est rendu compte que j'avais la
compétition n'a elle a eu envie de le
faire et s'il a des difficultés dans les
deux domaines dont la fin de compétition
il peut voir jusqu'où il peut aller
parce que les horaires d'entraînements
sont pratiques
en fin d'après-midi les autres sports
sont plus souvent le mercredi après midi
les parents travaillent donc on peut pas
forcément les emmener et puis elles se
sont rués une passion
merck
au jass
gasquet
les départs par catégories permettent de
voir aussi les différences de niveaux
mais ici l'émulation intergénérationnels
comme aymeric champions d'avenir qui
patine pas loin de son papa
nous